(rap music)
♪Yeah ♪
♪Okay, it's Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪Sippin' in for free ♪
♪I know patience is the key ♪
♪Puttin' out all a my shit for free ♪
♪This is Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪Mic'll make a flip ♪
♪Take a risk ♪
- Good morning, everybody.
Hope everybody's super well.
Tuesday morning in April.
First, thank you so much for everybody who
donated to the all in challenge.
I should be announcing my...
Raffles have to go through legalities
so, it ended on Saturday
but I should be announcing
the winner here any day.
Maybe even today so, thanks for that.
And thanks for tuning in.
Good morning, good morning, good morning.
Good morning, Bass.
Good morning David S.
Dave Hoffman,
Entisa, Zoa,
great to see you.
Thank you so much
Ryan, great to see you, Brad, Ahmed, Sarah
Tricia in the building.
Thank you all so much, Delilah,
thank you all so much
for being on this morning
on Tea with GaryVee.
Let's get into the show.
(buzzer buzzes)
Hello, Macy.
- Hey! (laughs)
- Good morning.
- I'm good, how are you?
Good morning'
Why are you up so early everyday?
- It's not that early.
Nine's not that early.
- Oh,
- You're on the West Coast?
- Yeah.
- Gotcha.
- Yeah great.
- I'm on Ohio time.
- You're in Ohio?
- I'm in New York, but
I know you're from Ohio.
- Oh yeah, I'm from Ohio.
(laughs)
- Hey, first, thank you so much for doing
the all in challenge.
It means a lot. I really appreciate it
- Yes, I actually don't know
how my whole thing is going
but I'm happy to do it.
I think it's a great
thing you guys are doing'
- We appreciate it.
How've you been?
How you going through all this?
- Oh, you know, stuck in
misery like everybody else
but, you know, working'
it, working' it out.
- Are you antsy?
Are you, like, really
really ready to get out?
- I mean, I've been goin' out, you know,
a highlight is like, goin' to Target.
(GaryVee laughs)
But...
I mean,
I want it to be safe.
I don't wanna just go out just to go out,
you know what I mean? I want
it to be the right time.
What do you think about all that?
- I think, now I'm stating'
to think a lot about how
everyone's gonna look back at this time
and miss it.
I'm already thinking'
about 18 months from now
and everyone's like,
man, that wasn't so bad.
You know, and so, I'm already
kind of laughing about the next part.
The only thing really
running through my mind is,
I hope we don't go back too soon.
Like, I don't think people have it in them
to go back, hardcore quarantine.
Like, in Japan, this one region,
people went out for, like, three weeks,
and then boom, they had
to go back for a month,
five weeks, and I just can't see America
dealing with that well.
- Yeah.
- Coming out and then boom, back in that.
I just think that people
are gonna go crazy
so, I'm hoping that we
wait that extra week
but, we'll see.
I mean, people are out there are ready.
- Yeah, like crazy.
- Like crazy.
Even, there's evening, traffic back in LA.
Like, before, we were enjoying no traffic
but, yesterday I went out and
it was backed up a little bit.
So, I don't know.
- You got any questions?
You got anything interesting going on?
- Um, okay for you?
Okay, so here's my question for GaryVee.
All right, so, as an artist,
recording artist,
actresses, blah blah blah,
you're kinda pulled aside in the beginning
and you're told not to really be open
about your politics because
you run the risk of...
- Alienating half the country.
- (laughs) People who
don't agree with you.
- Yeah, of course.
- Okay, so you know what I mean.
- Yes.
- So, what do you think of that?
Do you think that's, because of course,
everyone has an opinion
and there might be someone
who comes along and has
an opinion that matters
and that can make a
difference but they can't
express it because they're-
- I think it's a very
personal thing, right?
Obviously, everyone's going
crazy on this documentary
right now so, one of
the most famous cases,
you know, I'm a little bit
older, so one of the most
famous cases of all time
of somebody staying quiet
was Michael Jordan.
There was so much pressure
on him during his career
to talk about something besides sneakers
and he wouldn't go there
and that was his personal,
that's the way he put
his head on his pillow.
- Right.
- You know, he viewed himself that way.
On the flip side, a generation earlier
you had Mohamed Ali who
was the most famous athlete
in the world and he went completely there.
I think it's a personal thing, Macy.
Also, I also think that
you can quote on quote,
change your mind.
That might have worked
for you or somebody else
for a period of time and then
you can go the other way,
and vice versa.
So to me, it's like parenting a child.
There is no right, it's
only what's right for you.
But I think people have to figure out
what lets them put their
head on their pillow.
For a lot of people, they
choose lack of tension,
lack of chaos and dollars,
and stay quiet.
And other people don't have that in them
and they feel like they can impact
by being in front.
There's a lot of people who are famous
who do everything behind the scenes.
Spend a ton of time and
money behind the scenes,
trying to make an impact on the world.
I think it's a very very person decision.
I really do.
- But do you think that that's right?
Like, do you think that
it's cool to ask people
to be quiet just 'cause
they're a celebrity?
- No, of course not.
I think that's crazy.
I think that that
manager, that best friend,
that mom, that agent,
is saying something they
probably genuinely believe is in the best
interest of that person, however,
I also think it's crazy for that person
to listen blindly to
anybody but themselves.
- For instance, currently the
one I can think of is Kanye,
when he came out about
when he claimed
he was a Trump supporter.
And then, so, do you think
everything that happened
after was a result of that,
or do you think it was other things?
- I also think that people, you know,
everything that happened after that,
I think people are buying as many Yeezies
and I think if Kanye
puts out a fire album,
people are gonna listen to it.
Like, I think cancel culture
is boring, on both sides.
I think people may not
agree or you may disagree
or things of that nature but,
I think that...
I'm sure there are absolutely...
You know what I like to do?
I like to look at what people say
and then see what they do.
There's a ton of people
that were super mad at Kanye
in all sorts of sectors of the country
that, a year later, are re-tweeting him
about his Sunday services.
- Yeah, 'cause people seem to move on.
- 99%, Macy, they move on.
- Yeah.
- So, I think it's a
personal thing and I think,
like with anything,
you gotta make your call for
you 'cause you're sleeping
with that until the end.
- Well, what about someone like you?
Would you ever say who you're
gonna vote for in November
or is that too risky for you?
- I would say it.
I would say it.
I'm the kinda person that like...
I feel that America's so bad at dealing
with political issues, that
everyone's on such tilt
in every direction that,
everyone's a headline reader.
In a 45 minute conversation, I'm thrilled
to talk about anything
and a one sentence thing,
people get crazy.
Right?
To me, it's like, I'm just
fascinated by people's
inability to understand multi
layers of the conversation.
Meaning, I'm extremely comfortable...
Like, I voted for Hillary Clinton.
It's not super hard for me to say that.
I'm not, to me, you could Google that.
So, to me, I'm fine with that.
But I'm also okay with people
that don't agree with me
on that, but I'm okay with
people that don't agree
with me on anything.
People are living their lives.
I'm not worried about
their politics or anything.
As a matter of fact,
everything I talk about,
when it comes to business
and things of that nature,
I'm spitting what I
believe is generally right,
but I'm not worried
about people disagreeing
or disliking me.
There's people that don't
like me because I shit
on the Patriots and Michael Jordan 24/7.
You know, I'm okay with
people not agreeing with me.
To me, what I don't like
is the lack of humanity and kindness
You know, disagreeing is exactly right.
That's how you make good shit happen.
But people's feelings
are on tilt right now.
Everyone's in fourth fucking grade.
- It's a wild time, you know,
I don't think anybody, you know,
nobody was really set up for this
or told to prepare for this.
It's just real raw.
So that's why I was
asking, because I thought
this would be a time
where people would talk
about what they're really
feeling and really,
kind of be adamant about
what we should do in November
and stuff like that but,
I haven't heard it yet.
Maybe it's early.
- It's early, America...
And honestly, it would
not be early right now
but everybody right now is
worried about their family
and their loved ones.
- Yeah.
- We're deep in a global
pandemic, you know?
- Um hmm.
But do you think people, okay,
let me as you this, though.
Do you think people
care what artists think?
Like, I might say
something on my Instagram
and then I'll get a lot of
craziness
if I say anything political.
You know, people are always
say like, stick to singing,
stuff like that.
Do you think its...
Do you think anybody cares
what a celebrity thinks?
- I think people care
what their neighbor thinks
so, why wouldn't they care
what a celebrity thinks?
- But does it matter?
Like, in the scheme of things?
- Of course it matters.
- You think it matters?
- Of course it does.
People change the world.
It might be a celebrity,
it might be a politician,
it might be a pastor, it might
be a social media celebrity.
Yeah, of course it matters.
I think that most people think
too highly of themselves.
I think the world lacks humility.
- So, you can pull from
opposite directions on this one.
I think it matters and I think it,
potentially, doesn't matter.
But I think, not sharing
what is in your heart
is always a mistake.
- Right.
- Period.
- Yeah, period.
Binary.
- No matter who you are.
- I think that's good.
I think that's good.
- Me too.
- That actually taught me something
just now that I hadn't
thought about before.
- Thanks, Mace.
- GaryVee.
- Mace, let's chop and have
a real dinner after this.
I'm gonna have, we're gonna connect,
because I'm gonna move on with the show
but I really wanna spend some time.
- All right everybody go
to allinchallenge.com.
- See ya, Macy.
- Bye sweetie, bye bye.
- What a talented artist.
When her music came out, I was just like,
she just sang from her heart.
Good stuff.
All right, let's keep goin'.
- What's going on, Gary?
- What's up, Mike Z?
- I'm doing wonderful,
nothing like following up
a Grammy winner but, you know.
- Listen, she's a Grammy
winner and you look
fucking amazing in a
t-shirt and a Yankee hat.
Everyone's got their thing, Mike.
- I appreciate you, sir.
Can we get a virtual cheers here?
- Cheers, brother.
- I appreciate you, man.
So yeah, I feel like Charlie Bucket
winning the Golden Ticket right now.
So, my question for you is,
how do I turn my passion
of giving dating advice
and relationship tips into a career as
a certified dating coach
and public speaker?
- Yo, I think that's pretty cool.
I think a lotta people are doing that.
I think that, my big thing
on that is the model exists.
It's put out an ungodly
amount of free creative,
on the general themes that
you see, over and over.
What I do, right?
Like watch what I do, not what I say.
There's so many obvious patterns
in business that I'm able
to bring up over and over
and so I'm quick in these meetings,
whether it's the flower thing yesterday
that everybody got fired
up about or other things
of that nature so, you
know the matics in dating.
As a matter of fact, a lot
of what I see in business
translates to dating,
insecurities, confidence,
you know, all that stuff.
I think, you put out a ton of content
and then, very simply,
it becomes a lead gen
to your consulting business.
I think coaching has become
a little bit of like,
a tricky word, kinda like hustle.
I've had to change hustle to hard work
because people have taken the word hustle
and manipulated it as burnout,
and, like, unhealthy.
So, I'm like, okay, I
don't wanna be associated
with that, I want people
to be happy, not burnout,
so let me say hard work.
Mike, I would say
consulting has an elevated,
or strategist, dating
strategist, dating consultant
instead of coach,
I think dating coach, it
goes in the lower funnel,
kinda mucky land.
But, I think, if you
put out amazing content
and then people find your
website from your linked
URL on TikTok and Instagram,
and now, all of a sudden,
they're willing to pay you
$500 a month or $1,000 a week or,
whatever your business model is.
I think it's actually very easy, Mike.
- Yeah, I've been following
your content for, like,
five years now, so I know
all about 25 year old
life coaches, how you feel
about that, and everything.
- Listen, my big thing with
like, because life coaching
is a tough thing to say,
like life, without living it,
but dating, there's a 25
year old that could be...
And by the way, with life too,
I had a lot of wisdom at 25.
I think I'm a lot stronger at
44 by living it a little more
but, it's more that people are audacious.
And really, a lot of
life coaches really skew
into business coaches, and really skew
into, let me teach you how to make money
by you paying me, but
I've never made money,
by any other way than charging you.
So that's where it gets a little tricky.
But yeah, I think a
dating consulting service
that is on the back of
a ton of free content
especially on TikTok and Instagram
is a very fruitful opportunity.
- Yeah, I got on TikTok because of you.
- How's it goin'?
- 40,000 followers and growing.
- Good for you.
- I started doing a live chat every night
on back of the Kristen being Kristen chat,
kind of got the inspiration
from her, linked up with her,
so we're going to try and have each other
on each other's shows and whatnot.
- Mike, it's so funny, one
of, by far, the best things
of this Tea with GaryVee
project has been the community
that's been built from it.
Just watching all of you
interact in the chats
across the three live
platforms, it's been remarkable.
- Yeah, there's a dating
app that actually,
we got in contact with each
other. So, me and the draft
mate guy, because we literally
met through this chat.
- I love it.
- And even the marketing
person is from here.
I know you gotta get to other people.
If it's not too much, I'm in New York.
I'd love to have a drink and
meet you, if it's possible.
I'll come to you or do whatever.
- Hit up with Dustin.
I don't want to promise.
because I have no idea
what my world looks like,
but I'm not against it.
- Of course.
When we're all safe and Covid's over.
Yeah, I appreciate you brother, thank you
- Talk to you soon, take care.
Let's keep it going.
Yusuf, thank you so much.
Kelly Hill, thank you
so much for being here.
Naomi B, what's good?
Thank you so much, peter.
By the way, if you're watching right now,
on Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram or YouTube,
the community is
completely out of control.
Say hello, stop being shy, say hello.
And if you're saying
hello for the first time
put first hello.
I like to look at the
chat while I'm on, too.
Let's keep it goin'.
Michael.
- Hi Gary, how are you?
- I'm very well, how are you?
- Good, thank you.
Thank you for having me on.
This is quite the opportunity.
- Awesome, where you from?
- Ontario, Canada.
- Fantastic.
What can I help you with, my friend?
- Just a quick backstory,
I invented a corrective exercise tool
and I've been passing it out to coaches,
athletes, trainers.
So far, the feedback
I've gotten is positive,
but it's not translating
into my Instagram page
and, I guess my question is,
what methods could I be using
to generate more interest,
more activity towards the product?
'Cause it's not just
solely about the product,
it's my journey with trying to...
- How much content are you putting out?
- I try to put out every
day, if not every day,
every other day.
- Volume is an answer.
I think, also, you need to
lean into strengths, right?
Because, you're a chill
dude, so are you doing video?
Are you doing written?
Are you doing photos?
- I started with just
photos with a description
but I've tried to branch off into video.
I thought maybe that'd be more personable.
- And how is that going for you?
Do you feel comfortable or
is it kind of like a drag?
- One of the things I fear is
maybe it's my personality
that doesn't translate well.
- Yeah, by the way,
you'll appreciate this,
and this is not a negative.
Just interacting with
you, there's no question,
in an honest way, there would
be a debate if the straight
style, monotone, if
that's gonna translate,
but brother, the greatest
frustration of my career
was when blogging came
out in the early 2000's.
And I was right about email,
I was right about Google
Ad words, and now, there's
this new thing called blogging,
and I was dead.
It was the first time that I was mad
that I was bad at school, because I knew
that I couldn't write.
And it was super frustrating for me.
And obviously, I got
lucky, and YouTube came out
a couple years later and I
was like, well, you know,
this, I can do.
You know, one of the things
you may consider is leaning in.
Couple things for you to think about,
one, are you good at writing?
- Yeah, I get some help with it,
but I'm better articulated
in writing than I would be...
- I think photos.
I think Instagram's a place
where people can blog more.
Like, a nice photo and five paragraphs.
So, I think, that, you should test.
First of all, you need to
post three times a day,
straight up.
Number two, one of them has to be a photo,
maybe two a day, a nice photo
of somebody using the thing
or doing the thing or,
you know, your world.
Five paragraphs.
That would be interesting.
Number two,
you may wanna have a spokesperson
or other people in your
content is another place.
And then, the most important
part of this, believe it
or not, this is a little
bit of a left turn,
of course I believe that
social's super important,
but I also don't want
people to value social
over their businesses.
There's a ton of business
that are crushing,
doing extremely well, and
are not good at social media.
Now, I think that's
missing an opportunity,
but for example, you
may spend all your time
tryna be good at social,
and that will actually
take away time from building the business
as if social media didn't exist.
And if instead, you focus
on building the business
as if social media didn't
exist, which should then
build up the business
that allowed you to afford
to hire the Sasha group
or hire an internal person
to do your social media,
that might be a smarter strategy for you.
There's a lotta people
here who think social media
is some sort of magic
bullet and if you're on it,
everything will be good.
No, you have to be great at it.
And, a lotta people aren't
destined to be great at it,
but they might be great at their business.
They might be good at
sales, one on one stuff,
and then that then leads to the dollars
that leads for them to hire an agency.
I mean, that's why I
built The Sasha Group.
I built The Sasha Group
for half the people
in this chat right now because
media was too expensive
and my dad was a small business owner,
and so, I wanted to create
the greatest agency for that.
And for a lotta people,
that's the right move.
Or, if that's too expensive,
you can hire somebody
for 12 bucks an hour to do it.
So, you might wanna take
a more macro strategy.
I think a lotta times, people
aren't listening carefully
to what I'm saying.
I also think that I don't
have the luxury of things like
Tea with GaryVee where, I can
really explain this strategy,
which is, maybe social
media needs to be second.
Social media's the first thing that builds
most people's business.
Most, half.
The other half actually
should spend no time on it
'cause they're terrible at
it, and they should spend
all their time on actually
building up their business
which then kicks them cash
which then allows them to hire
an agency or an individual to drive
that part of their business.
That's just smart.
- Yeah, that makes more sense.
- Dustin, thesashagroup.com,
throw that up.
And let's get a graphic
with my dad's face,
I think that'll be funny.
Make sense, Michael?
- Yeah, that's actually
what I was gonna ask you,
if it was a more viable solution
to just have somebody else
kinda be a spokesperson of this thing?
- 100%, it's a more viable
solution to have somebody
else be the salesman, it's
a more viable solution
to have somebody be
the accountant and CFO,
you know, you have to
be able to afford it.
- Yeah.
- Which then means, you
have to look at yourself
and figure out what you're best at.
If you're spending seven
hours on getting out
one terrible post on
Instagram, that's a fucking
bad business strategy.
But you might be able to get on the phone
or write emails to people
and get your business going
and there's no shame in that.
I don't put social media on a pedestal
that everybody has to do it,
I just want everyone to realize
how good it can be when you do it right.
Not everybody's destined to be the person
that actually does that.
I do want you to
understand it a little bit
so you don't get ripped
off by The Sasha Group
or by somebody you hire, but
just enough to be dangerous,
not to be GaryVee.
- Understood, yeah.
- Awesome.
- Okay, thanks so much.
- You got it, Michael.
Good luck.
- Thanks.
- Good luck, take care.
- You too.
- Michael, one last thing
to you, and everybody else,
oh good, it jumped us in, Michael,
this is a machine or a process?
- No, it's, I guess the
best way to describe it,
it's a resistance band,
that loads the hip and legs
directly, so it kind of...
- Can I give you a huge piece of advice?
- Yeah.
- There's probably a ton...
What's your email?
- My email?
- Is this your Instagram?
- That's my Instagram, yes.
- Cool, throw that up, Dustin.
Everybody's watching
who thinks they're good
at social media, who,
Mike, what does this help?
People who have what, hip, leg, ass, what?
- It corrects pelvic tilt.
I don't wanna make any claims
'cause I don't have any
research, but that's the gist.
- I got it.
Let's go soft with it.
You're potentially working
on something that helps
fix the pelvic tilt.
- Yeah.
- That you're excited about
and have some confidence in.
- Yes.
- Good, so anybody who's watching...
- Gary?
I think you knocked out
your mic or something.
- Can you hear me now?
- Yeah.
- Good.
You can hear me?
- Yep.
- There we go, so, what does that help?
Does it help people's backs?
What does it really affect someone?
- Yeah, it's gonna affect the back,
it's gonna affect the core,
it's gonna affect the glutes.
- Good, so let's go right in here,
if you think you're good at social media,
DM Mike here, offer some
social, how much is your thing?
- Right now, I haven't
sold any officially.
I'm looking to retail it for $99.
- Awesome.
- But I've been giving them out for free
just for the feedback.
- Awesome
So, everybody who's watching right now,
if you think you're good at social media,
hit up Mike, make a barter.
He'll give you a $99 item,
you'll do a post for him.
Mike, you hit 50 different
people to do posts
in exchange for 50 units
and now everybody wins.
People are gonna fix their backs and live
for eight years longer,
and you're gonna get
a social media post.
That's way better than
what the fuck you can do.
- Yeah, thanks, appreciate that.
- You got it, brother, see ya.
- You too.
- All right.
Let's see.
Is it better?
- Yeah, it's like every time...
- I think I hit it.
I hit it.
Are we better now?
- Yeah, yeah, once I
pop windows in and out,
it kinda like, works again.
- Awesome, cool, thank you.
Let's keep it going.
- Hi, Gary.
(laughs)
I'm so happy to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you.
Where are you from?
- Well, that's the interesting question.
So I have a story to tell.
So let me tell you about my background.
I'm from Russia and I came
to the USA five years ago.
I opened a business right away.
I started with a coffee cart
in a little place, close to the beach
and it went really well, so I decided
to look for a good place
where I could be open
year round.
So, I opened up a cafe
where I'm sitting right now.
My cafe is called Sip of Europe.
So, I have five out of
five on Facebook, Yelp,
TripAdvisor and everything.
- Where are you?
- I'm in Portland, Maine.
- Portland, Maine, very cool.
- Yes, thank you.
- And what part of Russia are you from?
- Well, I was born in
the south of Russia like
Rostov-on-Don, but I was living in
St. Petersburg for the
biggest part of my life.
- Interesting.
- And after a year of successful
business with my cafe,
I'm making crepes and
crepe cakes, by the way
(laughs)
So I decided to expand a
little bit and expand the menu.
So I decided to learn some
baking and I wanted to bring
some no fat, low calorie deserts.
So I found the baker who
has the classes online
and I started learning how
to make different cakes.
And among those deserts,
there was one desert,
you probably know the name, if you don't,
your parents definitely
know, it's called zefir
- Of course.
- Yes, wow.
Oh my god, you will
laugh, I'm telling you.
You'll laugh because, so,
I tried making the no fat,
low calorie zefir and
I was like, oh my god,
this is so good,
this has like five ingredients,
absolutely delicious.
It's healthy and all that, I was like,
Wow, this is so great.
I should definitely go
somewhere with that.
Like, America needs this product.
I could be the only on who is
baking low calorie, no fat.
And when I start Googling,
I found out that no one,
no one in America was making
it and I was like oh, what.
I need to do something
about that so I was like,
Well, I should come up
with an idea of how to
trademark that name.
How to be, like, the one who brings
this desert to America.
so this is the part where you'll laugh.
I have a trademark for the word zefir,
(Gavvie laughs)
Exactly.
So, let me explain to everyone.
So, in Russia, the chik is the suffix
so it adds the caressing
word to the main word
that it's attached to.
So it's also going as chik zefir
which is also cool
because it's explaining
how beautiful my desert is.
So, I was so excited,
I was like, oh my god, they
need to bring it everywhere.
so I went to the big
expo in Portland, Maine.
I made over 2,000 of
those, everyone loved it.
I went to the local awards ceremonies.
I went on Kickstarter, not for the money
but to bring the
awareness for the product.
After that, I contacted
the Russian factories
and I talked to the
specialists, those who make that
you know, in industrial
way, and they gave me some
advice on developing the recipe and stuff.
So, I came back to the U.S.A,
I sent my stuff to the labs.
They said, Wow, it's
great, it's shelf stable,
it's amazing.
After that, I started contacting
huge companies in America.
Well, I have the trademarks in the U.S.A
and I also have the
trademarks pending in Canada.
So I started contacting big
companies, big food companies,
saying, Hey, is this an opportunity,
like, if you have a beverage
company, say, like Pepsi,
you can just have that
zefir chik because that's a
tangible cloud of flavor and you can have
any flavor in that so it's made of fruit.
It's kinda like that.
The companies wouldn't actually respond,
the only company that responded was Mars,
they were interested but they said that,
well, you know, no one
knows this product yet.
We're not planning on
advertising and marketing it
so if you go big with it
we'll be totally interested
in talking more about it.
And I had the pop up in New
York, I invited all the bloggers
they posted about me,
they told the stories.
And I made the Instagram
mask for the product,
I made some, you know,
heart pieces and stuff.
But the thing is, Americans
don't really understand
what it is.
- Of course they don't.
- Yes, for them it looks kinda nice
because in Russia when you're
talking about marshmallows
in Russia, you say that
that's American zefir.
Whereas here, I'm trying to explain
that zefir is Russian marshmallow
and I'm trying to give people to try it
and they try it and they
say, wow, that's amazing.
I feel like I've already
fed half of the Portland
with my zefir.
(Garyvee laughs)
But the thing is like, that
product needs acquired taste
so you kind of like have
to try to it, once, twice
and be like, oh my god, this is so great,
this is so tasty.
So I've been thinking how
I can bring it to that.
I even decided to have like
online training, education,
for people and I was like, oh my god,
I can try teaching Russians how to do this
because if you go on #zefir
in Russian
it will have over 800,000
posts, people know what it is.
Everyone who is speaking
Russian knows what it is,
so I had like deep Instagram
stream when I was cooking it
I had over 1000 people watching
me, who would just like
watch and repeat but that's
not exactly what I want to do.
I want everyone in America
and all over the world
to know what this product is.
Because I mean like, no one
knew about macaroni, right?
They were in France,
and all of a sudden they
are all over the world.
No one knew about pasteis de belem,
which are Portuguese, like the egg dessert
and the world knows about them now
and I kind of want to
spread my Russian heritage
and bring it to people.
- You can.
You know what America didn't know about?
Tacos.
- About you?
- Okay, yes, they didn't know about me
but let's stay in your lane.
Americans didn't know about Tacos,
now we fucking have Lebron James
talking about taco Tuesdays
Americans didn't know about
waffles a trillion years ago,
Italians brought over pizza,
like, guacamole meant
nothing to Americans.
Americans didn't know about anything
until somebody brings it.
So, zefir is religion
in a Russian community,
I mean, the fact that
you're in Portland Main
and getting Portland Mainers eating zefir
is probably the most exciting thing
that's happened on tea with Garyvee.
I love it.
Obviously your energy is on point.
I was letting you really roll there
because, A, you didn't take a breath
but B, it's because you really know
what the fuck you're talking about.
Yuli, I think the only, you
know, when I listen to you,
I think this is a foregone conclusion,
I just think that you need
to warp your head around,
it's going to take seven years.
- Well, that's what I'm afraid of.
- Why are you afraid of that?
That's a huge mistake.
You're actually going to pull this off,
you have the trademark.
You should be afraid of
to not taking seven years.
My biggest concern for you
is that in the same way that
you talk like me, your speed,
but you have that macro-patience.
You know, from coffee cart to this,
you're very creative by nature,
you're going a mile a minute.
I love that about you but
the number one vulnerability
you have is not being macro-patient.
You're not going to have
the whole of America
give the fuck about zefir,
you're not going to have coca cola
just write you a million dollar cheque
and put cola flavored zefir
in every fucking store.
You need to fucking grind for a decade
and then you may be able to pull it off
but you have the advantage
because you're the one
that has the most leverage
and the most to gain
with zefir becoming big.
Back to Russian culture,
when I was growing up
in Adesa, New Jersey, my mom
used to buy pomegranates,
because I like them.
- Yeah, I love it.
- Of course you love it,
you're fucking Russian.
It's huge in Russia,
pomegranate didn't mean shit,
my friends used to come to my house
and look at it and be like,
what's up with your weird apple?
And I'm like, that's not a fucking apple,
it's a crenulate dick,
they didn't understand.
And it took fucking 15 more
years for that weird palm juice
to get hot and then America
discovered pomegranates.
It's going to take a long time,
like you have to be on Jimmy Fallon
in three and a half years
because you have so much momentum
and he's fucking eating zefirs,
you know, on today's show.
It's going to take a long time.
Unless you understand
it's going to take you
seven to ten years for this to happen-
- I do.
- Okay.
- Because I've already been
doing this for three years now
and I understand that this takes patience,
and I have patience and I also
have enthusiasm and energy.
I am trying to make it
bigger, just bigger.
- Let me give you an idea.
I think you should go crazy on TikTok,
I think you should send a box of zefirs
to every single fucking little
Tiktok girl that exists.
(Yulia laughs)
I think you should create
something called the zefir dance
and you fucking do it.
Eat a fucking zefir while
you're fucking dancing.
- Well, the thing is like,
just like you have the name
and not everyone knows your first name,
so for you to create a different
nickname that you go with,
for people, they don't
know what zefir chik is.
So, I decided to go with another way,
I decided to create a page
saying like, my chik rose,
and have my desserts and everyone is like,
oh, I've seen those chik roses,
and they are like-
- Chik roses, got it.
- Yes, maybe I should get-
- I think you're going too narrow.
I think you should lean in
to the truth of the name.
I think you should call them
like, zecups, you know ,
if you want to really go American.
I also think zefir is fine,
people will fucking figure it out.
- I hope so.
- They're going to Americanize
it and call It like,
do you have that zefir?
They'll Americanize it a little bit
but I'm sure I don't say
guacamole right either.
So, I think that...
You know what's funny?
Honestly, the number one
thing that I want from you
is just an ungodly amount
of social media content.
Like, an ungodly amount.
How much are you posting, you?
- I have a few accounts right now
and posting like crazy for my
coffee shop because you know,
there is a situation
- No, you.
- Yes, I'm doing everything,
a one person business.
- No, I apologize, your personal brand.
- Well, right now I'm going
more on the coffee shop
that I have because...
- You.
- Well, not as much as I want
to but it can definitely...
- Why?
- Well, as I'm trying to say,
I have so much work with my coffee shop.
Because right now it's mother's day
and I have crepe cakes orders and stuff.
And I'm trying to come up with an idea
of how can I bring people,
telling my stories.
Because I'm telling my stories
on my Instagram account
about my coffee shop.
- Nice job Dustin.
You inspired Dustin.
Your stuff looks good.
- Thank you so much.
- I think you charmed Dustin.
Listen, this is why I'm
pushing you so hard.
Put that back up, Dustin.
You have to lean in to
your biggest superpower
and your biggest superpower
is your personality.
- Thank you.
- You need to put put content,
you would be a huge Tiktok star.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I'm trying.
- That's fine.
But you're not trying, because
if you're not executing
three times day, on three
Tiktoks, with you, your account,
then you're not trying.
- Okay.
- Go back to the teddy
beards, that's fucking cute.
- Those are marshmallows.
Because I was trying to go
with what Americans understand
and those ae like, you know,
marshmallows that you buy,
they're just like real marshmallows.
Yeah, I combine those as well, thank you.
- Listen, are you shipping nationally ?
- I can be shipping, I just
don't have any interest
from anyone to get it yet.
I'm giving it out for free-
- Do you have a Shopify store?
- Well, on my website,
which is down right now,
I have the-
- Why is it down?
- Woo commerce, Amazon did some changes.
- Got it.
- Amazon did some changes, job
dates and I'm working on it
- Yulia, listen to me.
Your breakthrough with zefir,
I think you should go all in with zefir.
I think it will work.
By the way, I don't want
to hurt your feelings,
I'm sure my mom's about to laugh.
I weirdly, was one of the few Russian kids
that didn't like it.
- Well, me too.
I don't like it, I didn't
like the regular one.
That's the point, I was so surprised
to the point of devoting my life to that
because in Russia it would only be like,
white, pink and brown,
depending on the coloring.
And the flavor would be
vanilla, strawberry and-
- Chocolate.
- Yeah, depending on
the artificial flavoring
and now you can just make
it with your own hands
using some fruit and it
will be done just like that,
within 30 minutes.
It's delicious.
- Listen to me, because I gotta move on,
you have to make your account,
your personal account,
on Tiktok-
- I have, Yulia sip of
Europe on Tiktok, yes.
- You have Yulia sip of Europe on Tiktok?
- Yes, Yulia Sip of Europe.
How many times have you posted on Tiktok?
- I am trying two or three
times a day, I have the roses,
the feed is full of you.
- Are you in there?
- Not me personally, I
have just the product.
- I want you personally.
Look what my mom just brought.
- Yes
(Yulia laughs)
- So listen, I think
you're on to something
I just think you really
need to lean in to yourself.
I think you are the star.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
I think you need to get over...
Are you private because you're Russian?
Is it ingrained in you
or are you okay putting
yourself out there?
- I'm absolutely fine, yes.
- Good.
You need to make three
Tiktok videos a day,
with you in it, not the product.
And you need to stay focused
because I think you can build
this zefir thing just like guacamole,
just like tacos, just
like pizza in the 1930's
or earlier than that.
Got it?
- Yes, thank you so much.
- Good luck.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome, Yulia.
That was fun.
All right, let's keep going.
- Oh my god.
- Hi.
- Dude, let me just tell you,
I have been waiting for two days.
I had to read bible verses
last night on fear and courage
so that my hands didn't shake
while I'm fucking talking to you dude.
- That's so awesome.
- You're like my Oprah Winfrey of dudes.
(Garyvee laughs)
I'm like so obsessed with you,
my husband is a little jealous.
He's like, Julie get off that!
It's Garyvee, I'm like,
I need to listen to what he has to say.
I'm so stoked.
I couldn't be more excited.
- Thank you.
- And what you're doing with the platform,
talking to people,
ordinary people like us,
dude, nobody does that shit.
It's so extraordinary,
I can't even tell you.
So, thank you for the opportunity,
it just means the world to me.
- Thank you.
- Anyway, I just wanted
to tell you my question,
get into it and...
So, my friend and I started
a podcast about a year
and a half ago called Fed up.
Really, the podcast is about
fighting stigmas and judgements.
We really want people to know like,
no matter what shit you're going through
somebody else has been through
it and is on the other side.
And the reason I started it is,
not to get too much into detail,
but at five years old I
started having panic attacks.
I was an eighties baby, so
there wasn't much information
on mental health and
really it was until college
where I just pulled myself
up from the bootstraps,
started going to the
library reading on shit.
I sort of self diagnosed...
To do with therapist,
was 15 years in therapy
dealing with everything
that I had to deal with.
I just said, I'm going to
do this shit on my own,
my life is worth living.
And I just said,
I want a place
for people to go
where it's like, you know what?
If you feel like shit you can
get a little comic relief.
We do like skits, like funny skits on live
where you can get something inspirational.
We quote you a lot.
And just listen to something that...
Have you ever felt like
nobody understands,
or fuck, I'm really alone
and then you hear something
and you're like, okay, I'm not that weird.
I'm not that alone, it
makes you feel good.
- Not only do I know, it's
the biggest driver of my life.
I think shadows lead to unhappiness.
- Right.
- We need to talk out here.
- Dude, and just shame.
People feel the shame and all this guilt
and the minute somebody says something
you're like fuck, you know what?
Okay, I feel better.
- 100%
- That was reason for the podcast
and really for...
But my question is, we've
been grinding it out,
I follow all the Garyvee,
the Tiktok, the Twitter,
the Facebook.
But I ran into,
I don't know if you
know Mark Manson's book,
"The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck."
Do you know that book?
- I've seen it at the airports.
- Anyway, it's an amazing
book, it's just amazing.
But what I wanted to ask you is,
what do you think about
society really telling us,
you know, if-
- Can I answer a question
before you say anything?
- Yes.
- Because it's really
funny, just even the way
that question was just asked,
it's hard for me to answer
because I can't hear society.
- Right.
- Like, it's really funny the
way your question just hit,
it was just super weird
that their was a pause
in the way you asked it.
- Right.
- My answer to your
question is, I don't know.
- Right.
- Because I can't hear that.
My relationship with
judgment is so extraordinary
and the level of guilt
I have with it, meaning,
oh my god, I am so blessed,
thank you so much for that,
is all I'm trying to do here
for the next fucking 60 years.
Is try to move everybody's
relationship with judgment
to the place where I'm at.
Do you know how unbeatable you are
when you can't hear the judgment?
- Right.
But honestly, my issue
is not the judgment,
because we have...
I can give three shits,
I have people telling me
you're not going to be
able go to that school
with the conversations we're having.
I can wipe my ass with that,
I've had judgment my whole life
My issue is the way things
are framed, where it's like
if you don't have a million
followers then you ain't shit.
- But that means you are hearing that.
Judgment isn't cousin Ricky telling you,
Hey, I don't like you
freckles, that's not judgment.
Real judgment is the words that
just came out of your mouth.
- Right.
How do you get over, for example,
seeing yourself really wanting
to put out that message,
you have a very small following
and just feeling like-
- I lived that.
- Dealing maybe with that own judgment.
- I lived that life.
I had a very small audience.
I didn't put a time limit on my impact.
- Right.
- You're young as fuck.
You have 70 fucking years
to make this impact.
The hell are you worried
about how many Tiktok followers you have?
- Right.
I guess it's because
I just want my message
to have a broader reach.
- But that's your own
ego, that's your own shit.
- For sure, I call myself
out on it all the time.
- So let's reframe it, let's
talk about the following.
You can have 800,000
followers on Instagram
but nobody is really hearing you,
they are just following you
because they think you're cute
or funny or weird, or interesting.
Or you could have 17
and one person heard you
and saved their lives.
I would argue you made a lot more impact
with 17 followers than 800,000.
There's people with six million followers
because they got tits and ass.
- Right.
- But are they saving someone's life?
There's nothing more of a waste of time
than having your self worth
wrapped up in a metric
on a social network.
- Right, and just letting go of that shit.
- I don't hear it.
It's also why this
conversation started off
with the right thing.
You know why I'm in here
with regular people?
Because I'm regular people,
because on the flip side,
I don't see my 7.9 either.
What?
- And what do you think
because your message is like,
just to get your message,
to broaden your reach.
What do you say to that?
- That's going to be on
the merit of your message.
- Right.
- Martin Luther King would be
fucking flexing on Instagram
right now.
Gandhi would be fucking
going ham on Tiktok.
- Right.
Yeah, I just feel like
people feel all this pressure
to like be-
- Because they're listening .
- The next big thing, and
all this stress and anxiety.
I want to let go of that shit.
- So let go.
- Yeah dude, that's why
I'm on here with you
because I know you'll
call me out on my shit.
- Yes, because you're telling
me you don't give a fuck
and then you completely give a fuck.
- I completely give a fuck.
(Garyvee laughs)
- Listen, I've been doing
enough therapy to know about
my own shit, dude, I have no problem.
- Listen, I got super love for you.
Listen, it's really easy.
It's really hard and it's really easy.
What's easy about it is understanding
that it's right there for you.
Honestly, it's just going into a cocoon,
it's kind of like working out .
It's like everyday,
realizing...
By the way, this is why
I've been yelling about,
I actually want Instagram and
the social networks to hide
following count, all numbers.
Hide them all.
- Right.
- I don't need them.
Like, hide them all.
- Right.
- People are just in high school.
- Yeah.
- People's social media following
is now like the car they drive.
People are like, social media sucks,
it's fucking everyone up.
I'm like, no it's not.
Why do you think people bought BMW's?
why do you think people
bought expensive sneakers?
Why do you think people
always try to impress others?
What do I feel about society's judgment?
I don't know because I haven't
heard that, for so long.
What do you think about just, let's say,
obviously I want my message
to grow, I want more eyes
on what we're doing to help more people,
because I felt so alone
for so fucking long
and I had nowhere to really go to.
I sort of had to like do it on my own.
My thing is, what do you feel
about, let's say I grind-
- So give.
To your point, so give.
Put out the content.
You just have to think about yourself.
Garyvee is the person, that
11 year old Gary Vaynerchuk,
wanted to look up to.
I'm living the life I
think that you should live.
I am the person, on social media,
that I would have looked up to.
So you need to be the
person that you needed
when you were a kid
and you need to realize
that if you find, if Carol
from fucking Ohio find you?
- We get emails all the time
with the small followers.
We have a super loyal small following.
- So stop saying small following.
- Right.
- Just start saying following
and just start saying,
people I'm trying to help.
People have to reverse it,
people are about themselves.
- You're right.
- People are looking for a blue check,
people are looking for a following count,
people are looking for a
cosign from a celebrity.
People are about themselves.
- I think sometimes I just think
about the following count
and then it fucks up the genuine...
- Of course
- People are telling me...
- If I listen to my-
- But I think people
struggle with that shit.
- No shit!
- They start thinking my shit ain't shit
because of this fucking number.
- I get it.
And on the flip side, in my world,
people don't have the humility
to do what I'm doing right now.
If I believed in my number,
I wouldn't do this shit,
you'd be a waste of my time
if I believed my number.
- Right.
- It works both ways.
People that don't have it
feel like they're nothing
and people that have it
think they're something
and neither are true.
- Right.
- I like that one.
That's what it is.
- That's a good one.
- It is a good one because
it's the fucking truth.
- My mother in law always used to tell me,
you're not that important and
the minute you realize that
your life will take off.
Just get over it.
- Your mother in law is
right, that's wisdom.
Like, it's super important.
I'm not unaware that I
was gifted some talent
and I'm doing something but
I don't fucking believe it.
I do not get high on my
own supply, I do not.
And I surely don't envy
anybody else, you know?
If you're impacting one
girl that looks like you,
thank god you had the inner strength
to go the fucking library, a lot didn't.
- Right.
- So what are we doing here?
You save one person's life or
make one person's life better
you fucking won.
- That's what my husband says,
get the fuck over yourself.
- Yeah, and by the way,
the second you start getting over yourself
you start going fast.
One of the things that really works for me
is by having such clarity
and calmness, I go so fast.
Which creates so much, which
then in essence creates
the thing that you're looking for.
The more you're not thinking,
the more you're going to be doing,
the more likely you're
going that unlocks the thing
that you actually wanted.
- Right.
- Giving is always the
path to the thing you want.
- Right.
Okay, Gary, thanks.
Do I owe you a check at the end of this?
(Rebecca laughs)
- Nope.
- Free therapy for the
first time in 15 years, man.
- Have a great day, thanks for being on.
- Okay, you too.
Thank you.
- Let's keep it going.
- Hi.
(Shanice chukles)
- How do you pronounce your name?
- It's Shanice.
- Shanice so nice to meet you.
- It's so nice to meet you.
I'm 21, I'm from Ireland,
this is crazy to me.
I've looked up to you for so long.
I have so many interests,
I'm interested in singing,
dancing, graphic design.
The minute you launched
Join Team Gary Vee,
I was on top of it.
I was creating and I wouldn't stop.
Luckily enough, I was so
grateful that my designs
were featured on the page
and I made so many amazing connections.
So, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- And you kept pushing on Tiktok
and I was like, right, I have to check out
and see what Tiktok is all about.
So I made an account and nearly
a year later I'm on like 64k
and that has given me
amazing opportunities.
I'm so grateful, you have no idea.
It's beyond what I could ever imagined
You've been such an
inspiration to me for so long.
I'm sorry, I'm so nervous.
- No, it's okay.
- I'm like stuttering out my words.
Basically, my question is,
because I have a lot of interests
I'm not sure what to be posting.
Because graphic design is my inspiration,
like, I've reached out to a lot of, like,
building up like Tiktokers.
My thing right now is making
animated profile pictures
and I've made a lot of
profile pictures for Tiktokers
so I'm using your advice in
the sense that like, free.
Free is the way to go.
- It's leverage.
- When you want to get
your content seen, yes.
- Especially when you
could afford for free,
especially when your work isn't
valuable to anybody just yet
It is a gateway in this
internet world, good for you.
- Yes, definitely.
I respect you so much.
- Thank you.
Are you saying, the question
comes in the form of,
just got all these different interests
so how should I be thinking
about putting out content?
- Yeah, I'm not even lying when I say
I have over 1200 videos on Tiktok.
I post so many times a
day and it's, kind of,
I'm linking my Instagram with my Tiktok.
I'm getting people to go
over and look at my designs
and I'm slowly growing on Instagram
because I realize how hard it is to grow.
But like I said, I'm using your advice,
being like, Hey I'll do
this for you for free
if you share this on your story, tag me,
let your friends know
that I did it for you.
That's my question, like,
should I zone in on one thing
or should I test different things?
- I mean, even the fact
that you used the word
taste different things means
you already know the answer.
(Shanice laughs)
- I do.
- You know it's so crazy to live a life
where, I think because I
actually was not well read
and I have my own vernacular.
And to just even hear you
say, taste different things,
it's so flattering.
- I've been watching you
for so long, like six years.
Honestly, constantly, non-stop.
You've changed my life completely.
My perspective on life, I
never would have thought
it would be like this.
- Listen to me, you're well on your way.
- My end goal is to be part
of the team Gary Vee one day.
I am going to make sure that happens.
- I mean look I'll be honest with you,
if we weren't going through
this crazy situation
and plus visas unfortunately,
have become super hard in the US,
but I would not bet against you.
Every chemical in my body just
said, Yes, she is going to.
(Shanice laughs)
Is there anything else can answer for you?
Obviously, this is like an interaction
more than a question
because I feel like you know the answers.
Is there genuinely something
that has been confusing?
You know, I come from so
many different angles,
sometimes people are like, Wait a minute,
didn't he say the opposite the other day?
Is there anything that
you need on a clarity?
As a matter of fact, when
everybody is watching right now,
so many of you have been
in the cocoon for so long.
I'm very open to questions that
are like, Hey Cary, you know
what you might think is challenging me,
I don't think it's a contradiction,
I think is a layered answer.
So, going forward on Tea With Garyvee,
if anybody has a clarification question,
I'm happy to answer it.
Anything like that come to mind?
- When it comes to posting content,
I know you say post as a much as you can
and as often as you can.
But when you're a designer,
when it comes to designing,
I know I spend a lot of time doing that
and I sometimes get burned
out but I keep on going.
Sometimes it just gets hard to do.
Do you recommend setting
limits for yourself
and knowing when to stop?
- 100%, I stop all the time.
- Yeah.
- Of course.
Anything that becomes stressful
or anxious or upsetting
needs to stop.
No matter how hard I go
I'm always willing to stop
if I don't feel it.
- Yeah, definitely.
- I always trust my feelings.
- Yes, because I feel
sometimes it gets very tiring,
although I love it with
an absolute passion,
I think I go to the
extreme and I go too far
and then I'm run down and
then I'm stressing out.
- Yeah, the rundown is gonna happen
because when you're loving it, inevitably,
you're not going to even feel it,
it's almost like adrenaline.
And then after the game you're like,
Why does everything hurt?
Right I was playing with adrenaline
and now my muscles hurt
or this injury hurts.
That's okay, I think that
what you wanna make sure...
You need to know that,
if you promised Charlie
that you were going to deliver something
but you feel rundown and
you were going to deliver it
on Tuesday night, it's
okay to send a message
and say, Hey, I feel a little rundown,
can I get this to you Wednesday mid-day?
- Yes.
- People are compassionate.
- Yes, definitely.
I have one more question.
Since I am hopefully going
to be working for you
in the future, can you
follow me back on Instagram?
- 100%, I'll do it right now on the spot.
(Rebecca laughs)
- Is it the same handle
as this right here?
- It is, yes.
Thank you so much.
- You are welcome so much
and thank you so much.
- Have the best day and I hope
you're keeping well and safe
during quarantine.
- 6144th, that's me.
(screams excitedly)
It's done.
- Such a dream.
- Thanks for being on
- Thank you.
- Take care, bye-bye.
- Bye
- Dustin.
- Yes, sir.
- Good show.
- Yeah.
- Fun, right?
- Uh-hum.
- Do we have the podcast ending?
- We do.
- We do?
I can't wait to see it.
Everybody who is watching,
one thing I realized with Tea with Garyvee
is the majority of you are
actually not subscribed
to my podcast.
You listen to it but you're
not subscribed on Spotify
or more importantly Apple.
Anybody with an Iphone, who's
not subscribed to the podcast
you're hurting my feelings.
So, we have a little bit
of a promotional thing
to inspire you.
If you've just subscribed to my podcast,
there is the URL, it's
garyvee.com/audioexperience
if you want the whole thing.
Or you can go to Apple
and just search Gary Vee audio experience.
I would love for you to get on board.
There's so much going on here,
I have a little bit of a concern
that Tea With Garyvee does
not continue post covid
but the way you can
get that hit is through
Tea with Garvee.
Also before I head out,
Wine text today, several people
are asking for the heads up
Today is a monster.
It's a wine from the Languadok in France
and it's 93 points from
one of the hardest critics
in the world.
So that's just crazy and
it's only $120 a bottle.
It's a big time red, for a
lot of you that drink $40, $50
reds or aspire to, it's a big time red.
So please sign up for winetext.com
if you buy wine in the US
It would mean the world to me
and please check this out.
(snaps finger)
I realized a lot of you
that watch Tea With Garyvve
aren't signed up for my podcast.
That makes me sad.
Here's what you're missing out on.
- No, you've like helped me so much.
- Thank you bro.
- And like navigating,
like, it's all mindset.
Like, when I entered college
I had such a bad mindset
because I was like I don't
really want to be here,
I just want to work.
But, like, listening to
the podcast everyday,
having positivity in my ears
has really just helped me along
- Gary, if the mindset has been skewed,
how can you bring it back?
And I answered with, by
surrounding yourself with people
who have the mindset you aspire to.
Mold, and I mean mold your
mindset by what you consume
and with whom you consume it.
If you think your life is
shit, your life is shit.
Keep listening to more of my content,
you need fucking positivity
coming through your ears.
Then, fucking, all that
negativity is coming in your head
put your fucking headphones
in and listen to positivity.
If you can't move out yet,
put shit in your ears.
You walk in, put the
fucking headphones on,
in your house, close your
door and fucking listen.
You can listen while you're driving,
you can listen while you're traveling.
You can listen while you're working out,
you can listen while
you're walking the dog.
Like, find your shit.
Don't listen to people that shit on you.
Get in your own head, put
positivity around you,
drop loser friends.
Like, that negativity that you're hearing,
you gotta get that the
fuck out of your life.
You need to put your fucking ear pods in
and listen to positivity 24/7
to get you through that
shit, you understand?
When your surroundings are
shit your inside's gotta
be positive.
The fact that you're even here
means you're fucking halfway home.
(inspiring music)